今いろんな方々が職場とか学校
ま過程においてストレス溜めた方多いですどんどんどんどん溜まってます
まあ学校教室上司
お子さんベッドでもいいです
それは何だか自分と合わないと思っている方が多いんじゃないでしょうか
それの一つの原因がパリコレなんですね
自分の個性とのミスマッチが起こっている
自分の個性と合わない選択をしている人が多いということです
私もともと素粒子原子核物理学留学もしてきました
ずーっと研究してきたんですけれどもその中で心理学や哲学
心の世界を移り学的なアプローチで見ていくこと
ずーっとやってきました
仕事とか恋愛人間関係こういうのも物理で語ると面白いですね
そこで一番いつも思っていたことがあります
個性って何だろう
どうやって物理で表現していけばいいんだろうというふうに考えてました
その答えが一つが
声だったんですねその一つのソリューションが故意にやりました
普段何気なく皆さんがた話してますけど重いとか感情が全部恋になって得てきています
思いや感情の音色が声っていう音になって出てきてるねっ
そういう意味では超えて心の音っていうことができます
例えばありがとうって言ってもすぐわかります
ありがとうあありがとう
ででもチュラン by たなぁ
また声ってその人固有のものです
その人の個性を表しています
その人を特定する指紋とか網膜
これと同じでこれを正門って言います
先ほどアントニは6秒間自分の名前を言いました
何をやったかって言ったら自分の名前いうと自分自身がそこに出てくるんです
自分という個性の音が自分の名前なんですね
これを統計立てて関して行っていろんな統計データをとって言って私が構築したものを
全品分析心理学とか名前をつけました
これは声の周波数を分解して
色の周波数変換し直しましたそれで心を可視化したソフトなんです
もともとが
特許からできていてそれを色の意味とか解釈の仕方
これ私が構築していったものです
物理学的に言うと色をとまぁ香り森狩りも同じ周波数でこれ表すことができるんですね
そして声を12色の色で変換しなおして心理学的に解釈していったものです
その人の強みや弱みといった特性とか個性が出てくるんです
ちょっとここでその枠組みをご説明します
人がどこで判断しているのか判断基準って言います
実はこれには3つあります
体の感覚で感じて判断していくたい感覚
耳で聴いて音で判断する超感覚
また目で見てビジュアルから判断していく時間各
此の三つがありますみなさんどれか持ってるんですね
また誰に酒店や動機があるのか
これも3つあります
これを行動基準という名前をつけました
まず視点が自分にある人これ自分軸
ます
色で打ったらイエローっていう色に対応しています
また貴方っていう相手軸
色でいうとターコイズっていう色対応してます
それから最後に
みんなのためにっていう社会軸より言ったらこれは
ませんだという色に対応しています
皆さん心って何回数あるか知っています
実はこれ3階層あるね頭でいろいろ考える
兼第二期これから中間とか曲
の全員資金で心の底にある
ぜんざい時期この3つです
まあこれはユングとかフロイトの心理学に出てきます
ちなみにこの絵知的障がい者の方が書いてくれました
すべての意識が同じ一つの道でつながっているという上です
なかなか素敵でしょ
はいここでちょっと事例を見てします
これは色が12色の色で表されています
一番外側の円が現在意識真ん中が全員式
一番内側を潜在意識と言います
この潜在意識の中で色が一番強く出ているところがその方の特性を表しています
実はコレ先ほどのアントニオなんです
あと兄の個性ってこうなってるよね
彼はまずブルーがすごく強いですブルーは見るという意味があって時間各タイプの彼は
人だと言えます
見て物事ビジュアルで判断していって最終的には直感で決めるっていう
そんな感じなんですね
これからまたあれイエローっていうのが内側にないです
その代わりにターコイズっていうのがすごく強く出ててあなたのために一生懸命所
自分をせてまであなたのために言ってやる素晴らしい人なんですね
してました皆さん
さてこの方イエローとグリーンがすごい強いです
グリーン脇口っていう意味があって超感覚タイプの人ということができます
聞いて物事を判断する人と例えば
伊藤名前とか声で覚えるんですね
ブルーがないので全く顔覚えてません
それからイエローがすごく強いので自分の考えや思いをどんどん出していく人です
この方
暖色系がすごく強く出ています
体で感じたりとか楽しいかどうかで判断する
大汗かくタイプの人です
ねここでゴールとっていうのが出てますけどゴールドってこれ弊社っていう
経営者がものすごく強く出ています他のやつは知ったこっちゃでいい
ちょっと俺様系な人です
次は動物の声を撮ってみました
左側がワンちゃんで右側がお猿さんです
これを見たらワンちゃんも猿さんも表面の体幹各部分がすごく遅れてます
皆さんワンちゃんとお猿さんの違いって何かわかりますか
お猿さんはサルヤマっていうのを作ります
つまり社会をつくるね japan にとって必要なことは相手とコミュニケーション
をとっていくことです
だから表面にグイーンとかターコイズがオサレなが強く出ています
それともう一つ面白いことが分かりましたお猿さんやワンちゃんに限らず動物はすべて
一番内側の潜在意識がないんですね
床やクジラで戻りましたけどこれなかったです
ということは潜在意識っていう心の奥底
深層心理は人間だけが持っているものじゃないか
私はそう思ってます
このあたりはまだまだデータが不足しているところでもっともっと出たがしてなところ
でもあります
さて先ほど言った行動基準誰のために行動するのか
声の統計とってみました
まずヒーローっていう自分のためにっていう自分軸の人は実は4%しかいないんですね
その代わりにあなたのためにっていう相手軸の人が入っ30%
みんなのためにいって言って社会事故だしていく人が20%言えます
このように人のために頑張る人はすごく多い
まあこのあたりは日本人らしいなと思います
このあたりは民族性とか国民性というのがあるのでじゃないかと思ってます
また
いろんなタイプの複合型も人もいて中にはまったく軸がない人が1%言います
この方職業を転々としていたり
日によって行動が違ってたりします
なかなか行きづらい人ともいい
さて他な私がカウンセリングとかいろんなことをした中で面白いデータをとっていき
ました
この方イエローとゴールドが表面すごく強く出ています
自分を出さなきゃやって一生懸命頑張っておられます
心がこの方は一番奥にあるのが
ターコイズっていう色がすごく強く出ています
ターコイズはあなたのためにっていう意味があって
人のために一生懸命頑張る人だと言えます
しかしながら今の状況としては相手がいない状況になっているんですね
相手がいずに自分を出さなきゃと一生懸命頑張っている形になります
お話を聞いたところ
子育てに大変苦労したお子さんがいらっしゃって
お子さんが学校卒業されていなくなったそうなんです
お子さんがいなくなったために表面のあなたが消えてしまったんです
その代わりに自分探しを一生懸命されています
なかなかでもできない
イエローっていう自分が家がないからなんですね
その方が言われました自分探しにきました
でそれに対して私が答えた答えは自分探しは相手たカチッっていう回答しました
江田氏名言だなぁと自分でも自画自賛しております
次のこの方
表面
この方表面 old yellow 内側にすごくあります
しかしながら外側がまったくなくて代わりに混ぜんだっているが強く出ています
つまりみんなのためにっていうのは表面がすごいんですね
これは
エゴを捨てなさいみんなのためにしなさい自分を出したらダメだと言われ続けた結果な
ん
自分を出すことを抑えられている
この方人間関係仕事かなり悩んでおられました
入ろうとかゴールドが強い方は自分の考えや自分のやりたいことを出していって結果と
して皆が助かる
そういうことをやるべきなんですね
この方は逆転してしまっています
次はこれ親子の正門を撮ってみました左側がお母さんで右側が
お子さんです
お母さんグリーンがすごいてよいです
ということは足なさいこうしなさいっていう話を一生懸命していきます
でお子さんは表面がグリーンが強いのであーいかなきゃーと一生懸命聞きます
でももともと家がないんですね聞いた端から忘れていってしまいます
声が外ていくんです
今日なるとお母さんがあなた何で聞いてないの木かなきゃダメでしょとどんどん
どんどんいます
そのうちお子さんがストレスを抱えてきます
そのストレスが身体にアトピーとか喘息とかなって出てくるんですね
この子はブルーがすごい強いですっていうことは目で見てビジュアルで物事を判断する
ことです
お話や会話をするよりもものを見せたり映像画像見せることでどんどん
分かっていく子なんですここでは親子のミスマッチが送っています
今声紋分析心理学
これは実はパソコンのソフトですこれを使っていまいらのところでデータをとってい
ます
データを取りながらいろんな分析解析をしております
先ほどの親子の事例にあったように子どものストレス
これを今小児科の方でデータを取ってもらったりとか
産婦人科や動物病院こういうとこでもいろんなデータをとって役立っています
この絵は知的障害者の施設で行っているところです
子供においては個性に合った指導や教育をしていく
個性を伸ばす教育をしていく
それが大人とか社会の役割なのではないか
私はそう思ってます
平成26年度企業において心マヤ前で労災認定された方が過去最高になったといいます
自分の個性と合わない職業についていたりとか
触手のミスマッチが起こっているのではないかと思います
自分の個性が見つけられない
どこを見つけて床を伸ばしていいかわからないという方が多いのではないでしょうか
一番重要なことはやっぱり自分を知ることです
自分を知って個性を生かしていくこれが一番重要なことではないでしょうか
十人十色っていう言葉があります
人間をヒューマンっていいますこれは色の人っていう意味があるんですね
人はそれぞれ色個性を持ってます
自分が持っている色や個性をどんどん出していって素敵な人生を歩んでいく
そうなることでみんなが幸せに暮らしていけるんじゃないかなと考えています
一番大事なことは
自分を生きるということではないでしょうか
ご静聴ありがとうございました